cagliari depuis longtemps la ville du
pétrole par excellence mais maintenant
elle est forcée de changer avec cette
image de championne de l'énergie en tête
qui toi on ne croyait pas déménager son
studio de jeux vidéo à calgary l'an
dernier le président de l'entreprise
américaine new world interactive voulez
consulter au canada ses employés
éparpillés à travers le monde
mais ils avaient les yeux rivés sur
toronto calgary a toutefois réussi à le
convaincre en se battant bec et ongles
pour l'attirer notamment lui promettant
de l'aide pour résoudre son principal
problème
oui d'où le talent c'est que new world
interactive et la première firme de jeux
vidéo à s'établir à calgary qui tourne
on est confiant d'obtenir une part du
fonds municipal de 100 millions de
dollars destinée à être versification
économique en arrachant ce fonds était
pour lui un argument de taille car il
devra développer le talent nécessaire
pour faire croître son entreprise pour
l'organisme et carragher économique
développment c'est un investissement à
long terme
robin biousse crois que les calgariens
commence à réaliser que leur ville peut
être une chef de file dans d'autres
secteurs que l'énergie comme la biologie
l'agriculture et la création et l estime
que cagliari al'avantage d'offrir une
meilleure qualité de vie que des mitres
paul très dispendieuse comme toronto et
vancouver
mais calgary pourraient bien reléguer
aux oubliettes son engagement envers la
diversification économique
si les prix du pétrole remontent comme
lors des dernières crises économiques
selon ce conseiller en affaires il y
avait au moins une discussion puis avait
on parlait de ce sujet là mais non les
prix revenait et puis
[Musique]
il estime que les différents
gouvernements devraient se concerter
pour accoucher d'un plan de
diversification à long terme je pense
qu'il n'a pas été manqué mais pour les
entreprises qui déménagent où naissent à
calgary les occasions d'affaires font
rêver car la crise économique peut aussi
être une occasion pour calgary de se
réinventer
il faudrait 9 heures radio canada
calgary